legends of the long night the targaryen
is used dragging about to decorate the
weapons without even knowing what the
first men used it for
you
hey everybody we have to talk all about
the secret history of Arya's dagger it's
important for plot this season but it
goes way beyond that so just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
so far there's also a new round of that
HBO now giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so there's been a lot of
theories about Arya what she's doing but
ever since we saw her dagger way back on
that Entertainment Weekly cover we've
been wondering oh man
the cat's-paws dagger what's it going to
be used for it belongs to Littlefinger
right now so maybe that means that she's
going to kill him with it and it'll be a
nice callback to Ned Stark having it in
season one some form of revenge in his
role in precipitating brans almost
eventual death in the ensuing chaos
chaos is a ladder that was that
Littlefinger quote where he implied that
the dagger was responsible for the war
of the five kings in everything that's
happened since then all this great
disaster but you say you know they
introduced special items in Game of
Thrones then pay them off later like now
they're teasing widows wail is going to
be a really big thing so maybe that will
become relevant again later in this
story or they introduced plot bombs like
Miss and I asking about pastors what's a
bastard I have no concept of that so
anytime they introduce something like
this especially this late in the game is
usually because they're laying track for
a big payoff most of you probably
understood immediately what that
bastards line was about in the episode
but the history of the cat's-paws
Valyrian dagger is totally fascinating
even before we learned about all the
extra things that Samwell discovered at
the Citadel about the Valerians and the
Targaryen adding dragonglass
to their weapons so way before season 7
war for the dawn stuff there was a lot
of conspiracies based on this dagger who
gave it to the catspaw because they're
correct when they say it would have been
extremely expensive even Tywin Lannister
had trouble finding Valyrian weapons
that's why he was so excited when they
got ice will melt it down and reforge it
into two swords I'll give one to Joffrey
I'll give the other to Jaime which he
then gave to Brienne
so it's established that Valyrian
weapons are extremely rare and extremely
valuable so the idea that they just pass
it around is a really big deal like why
Littlefinger give away something so
valuable who in the realm would have
that much money that they could give it
to an assassin - then kill bran with
certainly not Littlefinger at least it
wouldn't have originally been his but I
think it goes beyond that just tracing
this back to who had it in season one
who was the wealthy person that wanted
bran dead
it goes back even further than that
because nobody would have been able to
make it new in recent years the secret
of forging new Valyrian steel was lost
with the doom of Valyria so that means
that after the doom the only way to get
Valyrian steel would be either to buy it
on the secondary market from someone
that already owned it or to buy one and
then reforge it into a different weapon
like Tywin Lannister does so the dagger
itself is extremely precious extremely
valuable and because it has the
dragonglass hilt it means that it might
not have been reforged or if it was it
was done so long ago the current
reigning theory is that Tyrion when he's
recalling this conversation he overhears
Joffrey having with the Hound where he
hears Joffrey joking that you send a dog
to kill a wolf
so tyrion comes to the conclusion that
Joffrey stole the dagger from Robert
Baratheon and that's who it originally
belonged to and he hired the catspaw to
kill brand so that was way before we got
this extra mythology from Samwell at the
beginning of season seven so whether or
not you believe that Joffrey was the
person that hired the catspaw which I
actually do believe then that doesn't
answer the question of the true origin
of the dagger where it came from and
what it's going to be used for on the
show
other than probably killing Littlefinger
because they've been trying to draw that
conclusion Arya staring it in that way
the way that Littlefinger was
responsible for precipitating all this
chaos the comments that he made to Brant
this dagger started the war of the five
kings so if there's anything about the
TV show that they do really well is that
they set up information then pay it off
really well so they've been clearly
setting up the Littlefinger has
something to do with precipitating the
war the five Kings obviously we know
that because he helped poison Jon Arryn
and that's what led Robert Baratheon to
go ask Ned Stark to come be hand of the
king then the rest is history everything
at Winterfell happens the dagger comes
into play and things go completely
off the rails so there are so many
different reasons why each of these star
children might want little finger dead
brand for his role in the assassination
area because he's probably on her list
because she saw what happened in King's
Landing in Sansa for everything that
little fingers put her through probably
like the first worst thing that he did
to Santa was block her marriage to Loras
Tyrell that Varys was trying to arrange
that goes back to that chaos is a ladder
speech when little fingers telling Varys
boasting about all the things that he's
done to one-up Varys that's really the
set up but a lot of people now are like
okay so she has the Valyrian dagger she
kills Littlefinger with it but balerion
weapons are critical in the war for the
dawn does that mean that Arya is going
to be fighting White Walkers eventually
and I do think that the dagger will be
used to fight actual White Walkers but
it seems like it's even more special
than that because it's adored with the
very thing that was used to create the
night King the dragonglass
we know that Valyrian weapons are very
unique so it's no coincidence that this
exact weapon shows up in samwell's book
it's not like there's a bunch of these
daggers that all look the same which
makes you wonder how old is this book
now obviously books get re transcribed
so this book might not be thousands of
years old it might be something from the
last hundred years because we know that
the maesters didn't rise up till after
the wall was created and then even then
across the centuries the Targaryen would
add dragonglass to their weapons without
knowing anything about how the first men
used it so we know that there was a long
period in Westeros where people were not
reading about these things the way that
Samwell is doing now so think about
Robert Baratheon where did he get a
Targaryen weapon from he probably took
it as spoils of war when he became king
of the Seven Kingdoms he may have even
taken it off of Rhaegar Targaryen 'he's
dead body at the Trident so that's what
a lot of people think that this dagger
may have belonged to Rhaegar because
Samwell is reading books about the long
night in fighting White Walkers Rhaegar
was obsessed with the prophecy of the
prince who was promised he was one of
the wealthiest people in the kingdom and
as crown prince would have had access to
any information in the city
that he wanted so like Samwell can't get
in there because he needs a key it's a
section full of forbidden knowledge when
you're the Crown Prince you can do
pretty much whatever you want so he
could just blow right through there if
he wanted to we also know that Maester
Aemon on his deathbed was ranting about
Rhaegar and the truth of things the
truth of ice and fire the history of
dragons so you learned that he and
Rhaegar were in regular correspondence
in his later years and he may have also
found this book that Sam Wells reading
and learned the importance of the dagger
dragonglass fighting White Walkers but
also at the same time the prophecy of
the prince who was promised it having a
child with Lyanna stark that he thought
would be the culmination of that
prophecy so you have Rhaegar that's
trying to bring about the second coming
of azor Ahai with a very important
weapon capable of killing the night king
a lot of people think that the dagger
itself is actually one of the few things
that's capable of killing the night king
like a normal Valyrian steel sword or
just normal dragon glass by itself might
not be enough so that's really the
theory is that the dagger is critical to
killing the night king and it originally
belonged to Rhaegar which would mean
that it actually by rights belongs to
Jon Snow maybe we'll get lucky and see
it in a flashback we haven't had any
really cool brand flashbacks this season
I do think that they'll be more before
season 8 is over but obviously the
dagger this season is more about the
Littlefinger plot but I feel like it's
gonna be much bigger during season eight
in the war with the night king so you
say though if the dagger truly does
belong to John does that mean that John
will wield it eventually well think
about it this way he has a long claw now
that belongs to Sir Jorah Mormont by
right because it belonged to his father
but Jorah doesn't seem like the petty
type who would take it from him so if he
were to let Jon Snow keep his family's
heirloom then Jon Snow isn't gonna be
petty and take that from Arya so that
dagger probably belongs to Arya for good
now so this is really getting at a
speculation territory but think about it
this way why have they spent so much
time showing why Arya is such a capable
killer if you truly believe that she
could out match Brienne or anybody else
in the kingdom she's that badass you
would put that weapon in the hands of
the best assassin now that doesn't mean
that Arya is going to why
killing the night king that would be a
big payoff in a big reason to explain
why she has so many crazy Opie powers
but again that's just speculation I feel
like the dagger will still be very
important for fighting the night king I
do think that it belonged to Rhaegar
Targaryen and I do think that we'll find
out what its actual name is because all
Valyrian weapons have special names so
the only reason that we call it the
cat's-paws dagger is because that's the
assassins name that was using it we
don't know what its actual name is so
either it was created a long time ago or
Rhaegar himself had it reforged from
another Targaryen ancestral blade but
the way it appears in Sam Wells book
here just makes it sound like it
predates Rhaegar by a long time like
it's way more ancient than that so let
me know in the comments where do you
think that this dagger came from if it
appears in Sam wells book which
Targaryen did it used to belong to and
what do you think it's going to be used
for after they're done with it this
season do you think that it has larger
significance than we've learned so far
the other big question I should say is
its name so we can all speculate on
which blade it is because there are a
number of Targaryen blades like dark
sister Arya is the dark sister maybe
that's what it's called now I would
expect that if it's an original blade
and it wasn't reforged from the
legitimate dark sister then it has a
different name hopefully we'll find that
out I would be ok if they kept that
reveal like the actual name of the
dagger for Season eight as long as we
just learn how it's tied to Rhaegar and
what happened with it in the past where
did it come from so leave all your
requests for bonus videos they'll
probably be at least one more bonus
video on Sunday before the next episode
airs if you have any special requests
just let me know congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Maggie Dole ezel
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here for my episode 5
trailer video and click here for my
episode 4 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight